you see this nice office which in fact
is full of
scammers these laughing cheaters close
the deal again soon they won't be up to
it is this David from Geek it's David
are you sure your name is David yeah
yeah your name's CNU and I know
everything that you've been up to
midnight SB pretended to be a scammer's
victim so that while they were hacking
his data he could hack their cameras the
Blogger found the boss's wife computer
where he saw statistics and most Their
audience which was over 65 he also
uncovered a Google form with all the
data 1,500 victims were the scammers
earning
$569,000 in 15 months the scammers
themselves received only 1% of their
earnings before sending the information
to the police midnight SB launched a
telephone attack on scammers let's have
a look at that
together